bonjour merci de nous retrouver pour
file echo votre émission qui revient sur
l'actualité économique locale
on commence au site avec les titres de
cette édition est dans l'actualité de
cette semaine la première pierre de
l'entrée du quartier de villas roy a été
posée explications et retrouve sur ce
chantier de taille à guyancourt
alors que le contrat de travail est au
coeur des négociations entre syndicats
et patronat la cgpme désigné organisé
une réunion d'information à destination
des chefs d'entreprise pour tout
comprendre sur ces règles de base enfin
d'autres partis magazine initiative
originale le premier bar à sirops des
yvelines vient vous voyez l'état cheveux
et il est tenu par un artisan siro pied
nous vous le ferons découvrir et notre
tient cette semaine sera consacrée à la
pépinière d'entreprises de versailles
grand parc
quelles aides quelles solutions
apporte-t-elle notamment aux start up
pour répondre à ces questions en plateau
avec moi pour elle ça j'ai mon soir
bonsoir
bon vous êtes la directrice de la
pépinière notre pays de versailles grand
parc nous reviendrons avec vous sur ce
sujet mais avant cela passe en revue
l'actualité de la semaine
suppressions de postes chez areva la
nouvelle est tombée aujourd'hui 5 à 6000
suppressions de postes sont à attendre
dans le monde où quatre à cinq mille en
france
l'annoncé de ce plan social n'a pas
surpris mais il inquiète le géant
nucléaire a enregistré des pertes
importantes ces dernières années 4 8
milliards pour 2014 de mauvais résultats
qui ont pour conséquence une baisse des
effectifs et cela concernera le site de
montigny le bretonneux où travaillent à
peu près un millier de salariés
on ne sait pas encore comment cela va
impacter les effectifs yvelinois selon
la direction les négociations avec les
syndicats pour structurer le dialogue
social et la gestion des emplois et des
compétences et on court
areva prévoit également un milliard
d'euros d'économies sur les trois
prochaines années et je vous disais en
titre cette semaine la première pierre
du chantier de l'entrée du quartier de
villas roy a été posée c'est un chantier
d'envergure et comprend des logements
des bureaux et des commerces mais pas
seulement
distingué il ya quelques semaines par un
prix d'architecturé il devrait donner un
nouveau visage à ce quartier regardez ce
reportage réalisé avec william l ils
étaient nombreux mercredi à venir
assister à la pose de la première pierre
de l'entrée du quartier villars voir
certains futurs propriétaires et/ou déjà
présent appeler côté jardin le projet va
accueillir entre autres
83 logements un hôtel de 102 chambres et
une maison pluridisciplinaire de santé
dans la zone d'activité commerciale à
guyancourt le quartier de la roi déjà
une véritable dynamique et un bel
équilibre entre le logement
l'activité les équipements publics est
là avec d'entrée le quartier on viendra
terminer ce qui a été commencé
un chantier d'envergure face au
technocentre de renault ce projet au
budget de 40 millions d'euros s'étend
sur un périmètre de 20 mille mètres
carrés et se décompose en deux étapes
l'entrée du quartier de villas roi se
décompose sur deux terrains donc celui
ci qui est la première tranche est donc
idée était architecturalement d'avoir
une façade qui était très proche dans
son esprit entre la partie gauche là
qu'est la première tranche dans lequel
vous verrez donc l'hôtel et ensuite à
droite
les bureaux qui rend une architecture
qui sera assez similaire mme la seconde
étape comprend des immeubles bas et fait
la part belle à la végétation
une des raisons pour lesquelles le
projet a été lauréat du
prix régional des pyramides d'argent il
y a quelques semaines c'est un petit peu
l'équivalent des césars si vous voulez
pour le cinéma et ce projet il a été
distingué à la fois pour justement cette
multiplicité des usages dans un même
ensemble et puis en même temps pour sa
qualité architecturale
le résultat devrait être visible d'ici
2016 pour la première étape
et d'ici 2017 pour la seconde partie du
projet décidé il ya deux ans c'est une
opération stratégique
ça nous fait penser à l'avenir puisque
juste à quelques centaines de mètres
d'ici nous aurons la gav de cinq
adresses sur la ligne 18 donc c'est très
important et danser dans cette
perspective-là aussi que nous souhaitons
aménager le reste sigle du quartier de
villas froid donc voilà c'est symbolique
c'est important pour les habitants les
conséquences seront de taille
en plus des 1300 m² de commerces 14
spécialistes de santé vont s'implanter
dans la maison pluridisciplinaire
seulement six logements sont encore à
pourvoir
et l'événement a eu aujourd'hui ce midi
plus précisément la fondation banque
populaire val de france a remis à une
dotation à la fondation université de
versailles saint quentin en yvelines de
25000 euros
l'engagement de l'établissement bancaire
s'étalera sur trois ans pour un total de
75 mille euros ce montant va aider au
déploiement du cluster de compétences
vert et bleu et notamment une version
mobile
ce site est destiné à mettre en relation
des étudiants les enseignants chercheurs
les diplômés et les entreprises qui
peuvent poster des offres d'emploi à ce
jour 4500 profils ont été créés plus de
1000 recruteurs sont inscrits un
partenariat qui a mis plus d'un an être
signées ecoutez jean luc vsr au micro de
mélanie potiers ont ni vraiment à
l'université du territoire où les
politiques et les parents les
industriels font confiance d'un de
l'argent c'est une grande famille knox
est une reconnaissance pour diversifier
pour ses activités de formation de
recherche
nous a pas échappé que côté que c'est un
peu compliqué non seulement dans les
finances publiques également dans le
privé et il a beaucoup de sollicitations
beaucoup de sollicitations
il faut arriver jusqu'à la personne qui
a la possibilité de donner l'argent dans
une entreprise il faut arriver à ces
eaux faut arriver à solliciter à
personne d'avoir un rendez-vous la
convaincre que c'est intéressant d'avoir
un partenaire vous ça prend beaucoup de
temps et je vous disais en début
d'émission depuis plusieurs mois le
contrat de travail est au coeur des
préoccupations
les représentants du patronat met en
avant la peur de licencier pour
justifier leurs craintes d'embauché
alors que les ordinateurs les
organisations pardon patronales et
syndicales se réunissait ce jeudi au
siège du medef pour une quatrième séance
des violations de l'accord national
interprofessionnel de 2013 la cgpme
organisé ce matin une réunion
d'information sur ce thème pour rassurer
les patrons dont le cadre des jeudis de
l'excellence un reportage réalisé avec
william el est il intéressant
le nombre de chômeurs ne cesse
d'augmenter tandis que du côté des
employeurs la peur de l'embauché bien
présente chez bon nombre d'entre eux
c'était le thème de la réunion ce matin
proposé par la confédération générale
des petites et moyennes entreprises des
yvelines l'objectif dédramatiser l'acte
d'embauché sont importants un maximum
d'informations aux chefs d'entreprise on
a trop souvent des chefs d'entreprises
qui viennent me dire
c'est terminé je n'embauche plus c'est
trop compliqué le code du travail est
trop complexe je ne les retrouve pas on
a peur de ce qu'on connaît pas et donc
si on connaît un petit peu les règles de
base et bien on peut éventuellement
passer à l'acte dirait jurisprudence
code du travail les règles de forme à
connaître sont nombreuses une règle de
base tout à fait classique c'est que le
principe c'est le contrat travail à
durée indéterminée contrat travail a
duré invité madame déterminer qui peut
d'ailleurs ne pas être écrits qui peut
être verbale l'exception c'est le
contrat de travail à durée déterminée
dont vous ne pouvez avoir recours à un
salarié pour une durée déterminée que si
vous justifier d'un motif qui est prévu
par la loi et ce motif doit figurer
expressément dans contre un travail donc
il doit bien sûr y avait un contrat de
travail écrit ça m'a conforté dans le
fait qu'on est on a de bonnes pratiques
et puis ça m'a appris aussi avec les
échanges des autres participants donc
qu'il ya des nouveautés réglementaires à
appliquer bientôt parmi ces nouveautés
évoquées ce matin entretien
professionnel obligatoire tous les deux
ont pour les entreprises de plus de 50
salariés une obligation de l'employeur à
respecter sous peine de sanctions
financières
prochaine réunion prévue le 12 mai sur
le thème de la réforme de formation
professionnelle et je vous propose de
passer maintenant à notre entretien de
la salle
dans notre entretien cette semaine il
est question de la pépinière de
versailles grand parc et ses initiatives
et ses dynamiques pour en parler avec
mon plateau je le rappelle corinne sage
et donc la directice bri de versailles
grand parc la radio que nous voulons
voir dans le sujet précédent donc s'est
déroulée à la pépinière de versailles
grand parc c'est des choses sur
l'habitude de se passer chez vous au
sein des pépinières
oui tout à fait en fait notre bâtiment
dans un autre bâtiment nous avons une
grande salle de réunion que nous
utilisons nous mêmes pour nos propres
besoins nos propres animations mais que
nous ouvrons également mettons également
à disposition de nos partenaires qui
sont très connectés avec les activités
dany de concernant les jeunes
entreprises la création d'entreprises
telles que la cgpme c'est pour être la
chambre de commerce ou d'autres
associations qui évoluent dans cet
écosystème donc pour rappeler les
activités de donc là vers l'avenir de
versailles grand parc le but c'est
d'aider les entreprises à grandir ça
exactement et ça se traduit concrètement
une pépinière d'entreprise en général
c'est un bâtiment dans lequel nous
levons des bureaux dans certaines
structures ça peut être des ateliers
d'aidé voire même des laboratoires qui
sont ouverts à des jeunes entreprises en
cours de création ou qui ont en général
maximum de trois ans d'activité les
services les différents services qui
leur proposait c'est de l'accompagnement
c'est aussi des débuts rom si le stade
et du matériel alors je dirais
premièrement finalement il ya deux
grandes missions point de pépinière qui
est en général il ya d'ailleurs une
norme afnor qui recommande un certain
nombre de choses au niveau des
pépinières ces deux grands aspects c'est
quand même la structure immobilière
le bureau l'accueil la permanence
téléphonique etc et des services qu'on
va qualifier plus d'accompagnement
d'animation quel intérêt pour voilà je
sais pas un jeune entrepreneur imaginons
un designer en freelance de venir
prendre un bureau chez vous plutôt que
de rester travailler chez lui soit cette
personne peut rester chez lui
déjà une commission d'environnement
c'est pas toujours facile pour certaines
personnes de travail chez eux ils ont du
mal à distinguer à séparer la fonction
strictement personnels de la fonction
professionnelle
et également effectivement c'est un
moindre coût dans ce cas la dette
l'entreprise a besoin d'un environnement
plus professionnelle parce qu'elle se
développe parce que ça correspond bien à
cette personne
dans ce cas là il va plutôt aller vers
une structure type pépinières ou
d'autres locaux d'ailleurs lé avantage c
est vraiment dans un univers
professionnel être souvent ces
personnages comme garçons ont une
activité professionnelle de salariés par
le passé ils ont un peu de mal à se
retrouver tout seul dans une pépinière
d'entreprises
ils vont côtoyer chaque jour au
quotidien
d'autres personnes qui ont puisque ce en
plus dans les mêmes problématiques ou
sans nous les mêmes préoccupations donc
c'est ça les rassure également vous avez
29 entreprises que vous accueillez au
sein de la pépinière de versailles grand
parc
c'est ça aujourd'hui mais cela comment
se passe le processus de recrutement
parce qu'il y en a on ne peut pas venir
comme ça oui à versailles comme dans
beaucoup d'autres pépinière en général
il faut nous présenter un business plan
dossier de candidature qui nous permet
de prendre connaît de connaître la
personne et surtout de connaître
l'entreprise l'activité qui est projetée
qui existe s'il en trouvait ça déjà
quelques mois d'activité on va lui
demander de me joindre également des
éléments financiers prévisionnels ce qui
nous permet d'avoir une visibilité même
si ça n'est jamais certain sur
l'entreprise de toute façon derrière il
ya toujours un entretien au delà du
document papier qui va nous est transmis
par mail aurait le général et qu'elle
est pas projet vous aller plus
facilement accompagné alors à versailles
nous avons nous sommes une qualifions
une somme pépinière dites généralistes
et à dire qu'on va s'adresser dans les
fêtes essentiellement à des entreprises
de services b to be service entreprise
très peu de services à la personne
on en a deux pour le res 'b to b' et
quel que soit le secteur d'activité
finalement on s'est tous retrouvé des
services
deux du conseil du centre des secteurs
informatique également du commerce du
commerce interentreprises pas du
commerce de boutiques est-ce que
l'étiquette voilà versailles attire plus
il ya plus de start-up entreprises qui
veulent se faire accompagner pour
bénéficier du rayonnement de la ville
alors je pense que ça en tout cas ça
c'est plutôt positif c'est plutôt
favorable pour versailles
après ce qu on se rend compte qu'en
pépinière finalement la zone de
chalandise est assez limité donc
quelqu'un qui habitera marne-la-vallée
voire même à à l'opposé de du
département des yvelines a priori ne
viendra pas à versailles
sauf si vraiment pour lui c'est
incontournable quelle dynamique vous si
vous essayez précisément de mettre en
place à versailles et ce qui est des
choses particulières par rapport à
d'autres start-up peut-être on essaie
vraiment de 2,1 d'eau de répondre à la
problématique immobilière ils ont besoin
d'un bureau donc peut être souple des
conventions extrêmement souple évolutive
j'ai besoin d'un bureau peut être plus
tard j'aurai besoin de plusieurs bureaux
je dois partir finalement plus que prévu
pouvoir résilier mon contrat très très
vite donc c'est une souplesse une fille
tic est extrêmement importante pour les
jeunes entreprises qui ne maîtrise pas
finalement même à très court terme et a
fortiori à moyen terme leur avenir est
également dont deux de développer de
d'animer la structure qui va leur
permettre ainsi leur apporter à son
d'information de conseil
d'accompagnement le problème pour les
startups voilà on parle souvent du
palier des 3 ans c'est quand même sinon
c est ce qu à ce niveau là une des pires
depuis ça peut aider c'est apporter
quelque chose
alors nous pépinière nous n'apportons
pas de financement une aide financière
en revanche on est en général très très
bien connecté c'est le cas notamment à
versailles donc dans ce réseau de
partenaires dont on pourra quand même
bien orienté vers les réseaux de
business angels vers un peu plus vers
les banques vers les structures
d'accompagnement qui pourront aider
conseiller accompagner l'entreprise
le réseau c'est justement ce qui monte
le voilà des jeunes startups qui
commence c'est ça en un point clé c'est
un point très important oui
souvent les entreprises qui viennent
dans pépinière demander qu'est ce qui
peut faire la différence du ray chez moi
c'est certes je vais dans un univers
professionnel
certes je vais au c'est aussi la rupture
de l'isolément c'est aussi d'être
connecté à un environnement qui va
peut-être des fois leur faciliter la
tâche
le dynamique
les choses que vous essayez de mettre en
place voilà dans dans le territoire est
ce que c'est vraiment le l'impact du
réseau connecté avec les yvelines avec
paris quel un planning profonde que
c'est mettre en avant alors à aller sur
la pépinière à la pépinière considère
que c'est vraiment la connexion avec
l'écosystème des yvelines et bien sûr on
et puisqu'on est en ile de france aussi
on est repéré en hockey en tout cas on
essaie d'être en contact avec les
structures régionales que ça va être le
conseil régional paris-région
entreprises et toutes ces structures qui
rayonne au delà du simple territoire
qu'est l'eau je sais pas conseils vous
donneriez à une start up et qu'elle
aussi tard tu peux venir s'adresser à
vous peut-être pour se faire accompagner
en derniers mois en conclusion je dirais
vraiment prenante ruiz de ceux d'emma
démarrer c'est vraiment de bien évaluer
son vieillissement surtout son marché sa
clientèle puisque six pour moi c'est
vraiment ça le nerf de la guerre
merci cours il s'agit de devenir en
plateau avec nous nous continuons tout
de suite notre émission avec le chiffre
des semaines
9 c'est le nombre deux pépinières
d'entreprises existantes dans les
yvelines alors parmi eux il ya promo
paul il ya l'espace isaac newton
louveciennes ou encore versailles grand
parc dont nous venons de parler
en tout près de 400 bureaux un peu plus
ces ateliers sont disponibles sur le
territoire
il faut savoir qu'en france environ 4000
personnes travaillent dans des
entreprises hébergées les indicateurs de
taux de succès sont deux 81,5 % pour les
entreprises en pépinières et je vous
propose maintenant de passer à notre
parti les magazines avec l entreprise la
semaine
êtes vous déjà allé dans un bar à sirops
si ce n'est pas le cas vous pouvez aller
à l'alchimiste c'est le nom du premier
bar à sirops des yvelines
il est ouvert à chevreuse et il est tenu
par un artisan siro pied marque chenu 4
exact de 10 minutes à l'image et romain
respini au montage pour ce reportage
rafraîchissant du soleil une terrasse
est peut être la boisson de cet été à
chevreuse le sirop de poivre de tasmanie
ou de citron mais là le propriétaire de
ce bar à sirops ses marques chenu il est
ce qu'on appelle un sirop pied diplômé
d'un brevet de responsable
d'exploitation agricole dans le domaine
des plantes médicinales aromatiques et à
parfum il n'a cessé de se former
notamment auprès de l'institut français
du goût à tour aujourd'hui ils élaborent
lui même une quarantaine de cire aux
différents échanges régulièrement ses
recettes
je travaille en petit cul 20 ans grosses
cuves comme ça comme ça tu y vois là
j'ai un extracteur de jus à la vapeur
pour tout ce qui est fruits après j'ai
ma petite centrifugeuses et les agrumes
1 ça c'est mon travail mais je refuse
d'avoir une machine pourquoi ces les
agrumes ont trait presse à damas ça
c'est un mélange donc citron vert citron
jaune aimante donc fait un peu penser au
mojito donc alors qu'elle visait mais
mes préparations je travaille donc par
macération infusions décoctions de
plantes
bon là j'ai fait un sirop de sucre e
j'extrais jus des agrumes
donc c'est du pur jus de fruits que je
transforme en sirop et après je rajoute
les est d'amandes fraîches et saint
nazaire pendant à peu près quatre jours
le sirop pied a créé son entreprise il y
a deux ans maintenant et a vu son
chiffre d'affaires augmenter de 20 à 30%
cet événement d'origine sept expatriés
il y a des années dans le sud à uzès
avant de revenir à chevreuse pour ouvrir
son bar moi je mentais déjà sur paris
car cinq fois par an je me suis dit j'ai
une clientèle son pari c'est dommage de
rester dans le sud deux mois d'été où on
fonctionne bien correctement et partira
pas sur paris
sur une semaine sur paris qui vous
paraît en termes de chiffre d'affaires à
1 mois à uzès dans le sud de l'été les
loyers commerciaux sont bien plus
attractif ici que dans le sud de la
france environ trois fois moins cher
pour se financer
marc a également fait appel aussi de
financement participatif lots merci une
initiative
conseillé par le barc de chevreuse il
trouve ça très bien parce que ça
dynamise s'ils voulaient le l'activité
économique
salah dynamise salah responsabilise
il ya des échanges le jour de
l'ouverture il ya trois prêteurs qui
sont venus donc on a pu échanger pour
moi je trouve ça très très bien par
rapport à une banque un risque amoindri
et surtout en ancrage renforcé avec le
tissu local
il lui a permis de récupérer 7000 euros
une somme qu'il espère bientôt remboursé
sans pour autant s'éloigner de son mode
de travail artisanal associe partie sur
une moyenne on va dire de entre 800 et
1500 bouteilles
c'est à peu près ça faut que je tourne
une demi bouteille par mois parce que
c'est un produit un peu différent c'est
un produit à c'est une niche en une
niche qui intéresse les particuliers les
épiceries fines
les restaurateurs et déjà des acteurs
d'événements locaux
ça m'intéresse parce que ça soit sur la
route des quatre châteaux le trail des
lavoirs
on est sur le système des circuits
courts c'est à dire qu'on favorise le
commerce local et l'activité de marque
m'intéressait vraiment parce que bat
saint cyr au pied donc c'est un produit
artisanal et donc qui va complètement
avec ce qu'on développe sur la route des
quatre châteaux découverte j'irai de la
vallée de chevreuse a traversé de son
terroir
marc chenu a baptisé son bar
l'alchimiste en hommage au livre de
paulo coelho pour la seconde référence
il vous faudra à déguster ces sirops et
passons maintenant aux métiers la
semaine
cette semaine nous sommes allés à la
rencontre d'un apiculteur la récolte se
prépare pour ces passionnés de nature
souvent non professionnels qui
rencontrent de plus en plus de
difficultés nous sommes intéressés à
cette activité de plus en plus exposés
aux problématiques environnementales qui
impactent leurs économies portrait avec
william el est mélanie côté pour aller
voir les abeilles
il faut leur dire bonjour et pour leur
dire bonjour on va faire de la fumée
cela fait 30 ans que jacky boisseau
salue ses abeilles étape incontournable
pour avoir accès à leurs nids ancien
cadre chez renault il a commencé comme
beaucoup par passion une fois la
retraite
il s'y est complètement consacré au
concours de circonstances
j'ai été piqué la première fois et
j'avoue que ça m'a restait des traces
mais maintenant je ne gonfle plus vin
rouge constitue son cheptel en france 91
% des apiculteurs ne sont pas
professionnels il possède une à trente
ruches comme jacky on les appelle les
producteurs familiaux
pourtant même à ce niveau cette activité
demande un certain investissement
ça peut assez cher en terme
d'investissement il ya bien sûr les
ruches il ya les abeilles donc
globalement ça coûte à peu près 300
euros chaque
chaque ruche ensuite faut un extracteur
forains maturateur et vont ensuite faire
le renouvellement du matériel
globalement faux l'argent c'est
peut-être dix ou quinze mille euros au
total
chaque année l'apiculteur consacrent en
moyenne 600 euros à sa passion il faut
entretenir les ruches mais aussi
conserver les trente à cinquante mille
abeilles prison dans chacune d'elles une
ruche c'est à peu près 150 euros un
essaim d'abeilles c'est 150 euros une
tenue faut compter une centaine d'euros
disons que l'équipement pour avoir son
sa propre rue il faut compter un budget
de 450 euros à peu près dans quelques
semaines il sera temps de récolter au
château de plaisir alors avant il faut
vérifier où en est sa colonie pour
l'instant on sépare c'est pas à la
hauteur de nos espérances normalement ça
devrait être plein de miel du sein et
pour l'instant il n'y a pas grand chose
donc ici normalement tout ça c'est plein
de miel langues commencent à avoir un
petit peu de miel on peut éventuellement
le goûter il a encore très liquide il
est plutôt sous forme de nectar encore
parce qu'il n'a pas été transformé en
miel encore pour qu'il soit transformé
en miel faut que les alvéoles soit
operculés lorsque le miev est operculés
est bien c'est que le miel est mûr il
est à 18% mlp si les nectars 2015
annonce gourmand à plaisir et constate
l'augmentation des difficultés
rencontrées par la filière les espèces
invasives comme le frelon asiatique ou
le varois jacobson un acarien s'ajoutent
aux nuisances subies par les abeilles
je me rappelle dans les années 90 sur
une ruche faire 50 60 kg de miel sans
exception sans mortalités d'abeilles
actuellement on est dans des situations
un peu plus un peu plus critiques n'ont
pas lié à la pollution mais liée à des
phénomènes météorologiques qui vient
perturbe donc l'activité et le cycle
normal donc de développement des
colonies une bonne récolte c'est environ
60 kilos de miel par ruche
mais tout ne se passe pas toujours aussi
bien soit qu'on à 0 soit que au
printemps on a des abeilles qui est des
russes qui sont qui meurt et ça c'est
une catastrophe pour l'agriculture et
aussi pour l'apiculteur c'est un deuil
avec des stages d'initiation et des
conférences données à la ferme de gally
ou au potager du roi il tente de
sensibiliser les gens aux problèmes
rencontrés par la filière en france le
nombre d'apiculteurs reste stable en
revanche entre 2011 et 2014 la
production de miel a baissé de moitié
elle est passée de 20 mille à dix mille
tonnes en trois ans et pour les amateurs
sachez que la récolte se fait entre la
fin du mois de mai et le début du mois
de juin
c'est maintenant la fin de notre
émission merci de nous avoir suivis je
vous souhaite une très bonne soirée je
vous donne rendez vous jeudi prochain
pour un nouveau numéro de fil échos